hello and welcome to the shaky science
show where today we are back with
another senescence video
yay so senescent cells cells that stop
dividing and to create a bunch of
inflammatory factors
increase in number with age there are
different ways in which a cell can
become senescent
and so there are many variations in
senescent cells
there's increasing evidence that this
increase in number
isn't just correlative but is instead
driving aging in different tissues
resulting in loss of tissue function
therefore there is interest in
understanding the action and impact of
different drugs
that can target cellulase in essence
known as sonotherapeutics
we spoke about this recently but
basically you can split sono
therapeutics into three different
categories
and so the first strategy works by
killing senescent cells
referred to as analytics the second
strategy involves inhibiting the
pro-inflammatory secretory phenotype of
senescent cells
referred to as sonomorphics and the last
approach is to
activate our endogenous synalytic system
referred to as immune surveillance and
so it's this latter strategy
that i didn't really cover in so much
detail in that previous video that we'll
talk about more in this video
as we'll discuss two recent publications
the first start is a nature paper that
shows a relationship between senescent
immune cells and the accumulation of
tissue dysfunction
and a second article that shows
activating invariant natural killer t
cells can coordinate removal or
senescent cells
and so once we've taken a look at those
two papers i'll kind of wrap up my
thoughts together
so if you've been a subscriber for a
while now you're probably familiar with
the concept of cellulosin essence
and the idea that it is a sulfate that
can be thought of as a tumor-suppressive
mechanism
to prevent damaged cells from further
replicating
but it also has their
senescence-associated secretary
phenotype
known as the sasp which are thought to
mediate the pathophysiological effects
such as reinforcing and spreading
senescence
and activating the immune system to
clear senescent cells
and so if the cells aren't cleared it
could result in chronic inflammation
which could have deleterious pro-aging
effects
and so this immune-mediated clearance is
known as immune to valence
and one of the reasons that senescent
cells are thought to increase with age
is due to a decline in the activity of
the immune system
and this reduction in the ability of the
immune system to mount an immune
response is referred to as immunosine
essence
and it's thought to explain why there
are age-dependent changes
in increased disease susceptibility and
reduction in the effectiveness of
vaccines
but this is so unclear and so in this
first study they wanted to further
explore
the impacts of immune system aging to
organismal aging
and to do that they wanted to
effectively enhance aging
accelerate aging in the immune cells so
that they could see the impact on the
rest of the body
so they developed a mouse model whereby
using a genetic tool
they could reduce the ability of a cell
to repair dna damage
only in hematopoietic cells which are
cells that give rise to all the blood
cells
including the innate immune cells like
your t cells and b
cells and so with reduced dna repair
capability
it results in the accumulation of
endogenous oxidative lesions
and tenescent cells and because it'll be
relevant for when i show you all the
different figures later
the way that they do this is by
effectively knocking out the gene
ercc one and so if you see that
from now on that's the gene that they've
knocked out
and the authors of this paper i've
already shown that
when this gene is knocked out in all
cells of a mouse
it results in the accumulation of
senescent cells in several tissues
but here in this case they're only
eliminating it from the hematopoietic
cells
so cool i hope that made some sense and
so despite deficiencies in the dna
repair machinery of the immune cells and
these mice
when these mites were young they still
looked like wild-type mice
and the symptoms only seem to manifest
later in life
notably one of the first observations
was a reduction in white blood cell
count
which was not affected in younger mice
but after around six months of age
now whilst the model didn't fully
recapitulate what happens in the immune
system of naturally age mice
it showed that it did induce an
accelerated degenerative process in the
immune system
as there was a reduced immune response
in these erct1 defective mice
when they treated the mice with
immunogenic protein known as klh
and so this reduced immune response is
similar to what's seen in
observational human studies and along
with this reduced immune response
they also observed increased expression
of senescence markers in immune cells
that induce a cell
cycle arrest as well as increased
expression of sas components compared to
controls
suggesting that more of these immune
cells were themselves becoming senescent
but the interesting finding was that
they found that the aged immune system
also drove senescence and loss of tissue
homeostasis
in non-immune organs for example in
these figures that i'm showing now
you can see increased p16 and p21
expression
in many different tissue types compared
to the control
and this was seen in the old ercc one
defective mice
and this also correlated with a reduced
lifespan
in these mice as well so it also
suggested that
immune senescence was preceding
peripheral senescence
so going back to what i was saying
earlier about potential reduced immune
surveillance
whereby is this reduced immune response
that could be correlating with the
increased presence of senescent cells
but to analyze this link further they
then did some pretty cool techniques
the first approach involved taking
splenocytes from these ercc one
defective mice and transplanting them
into a reporter mouse
that can be used to identify senescent
cells using luciferase
and so splenocytes are just white blood
cells taken from the spleen
and what they found was that splenocytes
taken from these mice
significantly increased levels of
luciferase signals
at one and two weeks after
transplantation compared to splenocytes
from
control mice and so this will kind of
suggest though that
these aged splenocytes can drive cell
non-autonomous senescence
in several tissues through what they
refer to as a gain of function mechanism
but in addition to their scalar function
they also looked to see if there was a
lot of function
to explain the increase in senescent
cells so this time they took splenocytes
from
young mice and gave those young
splenocytes
to the er cc1 defective mice and they
found that it reduced senescence in
several tissues
so in many ways it kind of rescued the
phenotype
and so this supported that there was a
lot of function mechanism
in which the aged immune cells are
unable to suppress senescence
so so far the work supports a connection
between a senescent immune system
driving systemic aging by both a loss of
function
and again a function and so in terms of
therapeutic relevance
in the last part of this paper they gave
three-month-old mice
rapamycin for six weeks and they saw
that it rescued
the loss of function and suppressed the
gain of function impacts that we've just
discussed
and so given that robomycin is
considered a semimorphic
which are described to suppress the
secretory phenotype
it suggests that reduced secretion of
these inflammatory factors
could be behind the cell non-autonomous
effects whereby the susp of the immune
cells could be driving senescence in the
other tissues
but i don't think that can be concluded
for certain at the moment
however speaking of rapamycin it's also
just worth mentioning here as well
in case you haven't heard the news that
there is a large clinical trial
named participatory evaluation of aging
with rapamycin for longevity study
or pearl that will be the first study to
see if rapamycin works as well in humans
as it does in mice
while they're planning to follow up 200
participants over 12 months testing four
different
rapamytin dosing regimens in a
double-blind
randomized placebo-controlled trial i'll
provide some links for some
more information about those studies if
you're interested
anyway to summarize this first paper the
authors conclude that targeting
senescent immune cells with synalytic
drugs
has great potential for suppressing
multi morbidities of old age
and so this leads me on to briefly
mentioning the second study
that shows some new insights into the
endogenous mechanism
of senescent cell clearance immune to
valence as we've been talking about in
this video
and so i won't go into as much detail as
i've just done in that first paper
mainly because the authors have already
made a mini video describing it
in detail if you are interested anyway
what they show in this study is that
there is a class of t
cells known as invariant natural killer
t cells
that are involved in the removal of
pathologic senescent cells
for example they demonstrate that
senescence prodipicites
so fat cells that accumulate in mice fed
in a chronic high fat diet
can be reduced by activating these
natural killer t cells
which can be activated by providing the
mice with alpha galactosyl ceramides
activation of these t cells reduced the
number of senescent cells
and also improved glucose control in
these mice
and so this is a nice example of the
third strategy of my
xenotherapeutic tree which i spoke about
before
whereby activating our endogenous
sonolytic immune
could be another therapeutic option that
is worth keeping an eye on for the
treatment of age-associated diseases
and potentially aging itself as this
would help to
mediate the failure of the immune
surveillance to efficiently recognize
and target senescent cell clearance
that we think could be resulting in the
accumulation of senescent cells in the
first place
along with the fact that whilst there's
a lot of potential for psenolytics
there are also still some concerns about
the long-term safety of psenalytics as a
treatment
option so it's good to explore these
other alternative
methods as well but basically
understanding how immune cells are
involved in senescent cell clearance
along with how they become senescent and
damaged themselves
are very interesting topics at the
moment and i expect that we will hear
much more details and insights into this
very soon
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters
and thank you for listening